I want to tell you about a neat
variation on scans called
Segmented Scans.
Now, suppose I give you this array.
And let's say that you want to perform
a scan not on the entire array, but
you want to do a bunch of independent
scans on segments of the array.
In this case the example is
broken up into four segments.
Now suppose to tell you where
the boundaries start and
end I give you an array of flags.
Flags are Boolean with a true
value wherever a segment begins.
Were you doing things sequentially you
might use the following algorithm.
So the algorithm iterates over all
elements and it looks at the flag array.
If the flag is set, meaning it's true,
then the algorithm does nothing,
basically leaves
the value A sub i alone.
Otherwise, it does a scan.
This computation looks tantalizingly
like a scan, except for
this pesky conditional check.
So what if we did the following?
I'm going to define a new kind of value,
which I've labeled here as Xi.
This Xi is basically a two pole,
or in this case a pair.
The pair consists of one value from
the array and the corresponding flag.
Now from this new data type,
let's define a new funny
operator that I'll call op.
Op takes two pairs and
basically implements something
that looks a heck of a lot like
the body of this for loop.
It checks the flag of
this second object.
Now if that flag is false,
meaning we don't take the if,
then it just returns the second value.
Otherwise, it returns a special
value that combines the two inputs.
Now notice this is the usual addition,
which we would see in a scan.
And this is a logical or operation,
since we're operating on Boolean flags.
Now I claim, if you have this operator
you can re-write the segmented
ad scan from before in a different way.
Let's see how.
Here's our operator from before,
and here's the new implementation
of segmented add scan.
First, we'll declare a new
array to hold these pairs.
And notice it starts at
zero instead of one, so
they're actually N plus one such pairs.
This next snippet of code
actually builds the array X.
You'll notice it builds the pairs but
it also builds a special initial value,
which is set to zero and false.
And fact, zero and
false are the identity elements for
the two operators,
addition and logical or.
Once X is all set up, we can do
a scan using our funny new operator.
And finally the routine only needs
to return the updated scan values.
So there's a final little
loop here to extract
the left most element of each pair.
The left most element being this guy.
Now you should compare this new
segmented scan with the old one and
convince yourself that this new
implementation computes the same thing.